I thought Master was different
[Music]
big finish time and as selected by my
wonderful supporters over on patreon
join now help make the show better
I'll get the plug out of the way early
I'll still do it again at the end
anyways this time I'm tackling Omega
which is of course kind of a a little
bit part of a trilogy they're not
actually story wise linked as far as
like that continuing narrative or
anything like that but you know there is
a thematic relevance between three
episodes those being master which have
already done Omega and Davros which I'll
get to so this one like master before it
focuses pretty seriously on a noted
villain of classic Doctor Who and uses
that as the title character now this one
this is a fifth doctor adventure so
we've got Peter Davison back and it's
whoa boy I'm trying to think of how one
describes this story um okay
here we go so plot wise what we have is
we have a basically a tourist trap this
thing that kind of this ship that just
kind of goes through historically
relevant portions of the galaxy and you
know you have guides talking about what
went on you also have actors reenacting
you know playing the parts of certain
key historical figures and all of that
and this particular ship that this story
is centered on happens to be traveling
around where the character of Omega was
basically lost to the antimatter
universe so suppose I should give a bit
of context for that for anyone who
doesn't know the character from classic
who's so oh my go was one of the time
who actually kind of predates the term
Time Lord but he helped his actions his
science his study helped gain the gala
frames the power of time-travel him and
Rassilon and the other which I'm not
sure I ever got established in canon as
existing and definitely never panned out
as to what they were gonna do with that
so I'm not even gonna touch that but he
was basically kind of sacrificed and not
it not necessarily deliberately at least
he certainly didn't know what was gonna
happen to him so in the process of kind
of harnessing this dying star and
everything that was going on he was lost
to the antimatter universe which is
actually where we first encountered him
back in the three doctors where he first
turned up and he then later will return
an arc of infinity basically he felt
abandoned by the Time Lords he felt
abandoned and and forgotten and he's
stuck in this place that yes he's
basically the overlord of but it's just
him and he goes mad and he wants revenge
and he wants to come back to our
universe but you know when matter and
antimatter meet it's not good so him
coming back has never really been an
option and so that's that's the premise
under which the doctor has defeated him
previously so this like master before it
well I say before that's you know I
don't know the order that these were
released and so before it for me in my
listening order it delves into the
history and gives additional information
and details on the background of this
character one thing that I do like about
this one particularly if I'm going to
compare it to master is because of the
way that we are granted these pieces of
information and who they're coming from
and how they're being relayed and what's
being said and the circumstances it's a
little bit like The Killing Joke in that
the sword
is so unreliable not necessarily
deliberately but because omegas nuts
he's he's off his rocker I mean that's
demonstrated in story here that's not
just like extra context that it means
that if at the end of this what gets
implied is something that doesn't sit
well with you you actually don't have to
accept it you can choose to believe that
okay maybe there's something like that
but like his version of has got to be
jumbled because his mind's a mess and I
like that that is in there and you have
that ability to adjust your own head can
err on the information that's given in
there I would have appreciated that in
something like master where what they
laid out I kind of still have very mixed
feelings about in general and I'm not
entirely sure if I like where is this
again they kind of did something that
I'm not sure I like as far as the
specifics of the backstory but I also
don't have to accept it so the fact that
I'm not sure that I like it isn't as
much of a detriment to me in this
particular story so anyway he's coming
back to the plot I've gone off on a
tangent way early not too much in this
boys I don't think that was all kind of
general stuff I was talking about so
coming back to the plot so you've got
this ship that's that sort of touring
this area and you have you know actors
portraying Rassilon and his assistant -
supposedly betrayed him and and I'm
sorry not wrestling Omega
rasslin doesn't appear in this but he's
he's a figure in Omegas past so his name
comes up so you've got all this going on
and obviously the doctor shows up and
then you start to realize that Omega is
again kind of making his presence in our
universe known in some way and the
doctor has to figure out how he's going
to deal with that and there's some
interesting shifts in terms of the
character of Omega himself certainly he
is he's handled differently and it
doesn't come across as just inconsistent
writing because as I
the character his brain is so addled
at this point that and and and yo he
goes through these crazy mood swings and
it really it feels justified the ways in
which this differs from how we've seen
Omega previously the the guy voicing him
and I am forgetting the name if I
remember I'll put it up right there but
the guy voicing him he he did it for our
convinient I like his work here better
than an arc of infinity I think it's
because he does Omega better when Omega
is calmer when Omega gets really upset
does the birds booming voice dr. I will
destroy you he's just kind of generic
but when he gets to play those calmer
moments which there are actually plenty
of it's not like it's an exception he
brings a lot of depth and a lot of
nuance to it so he I do think his
performance here is better because the
way the characters written plays to what
he is able to do as a performer better
whereas the big bellowing moments are
they're just that they're begging
bellowing and kind of generic Peter
Davison is the doctor and this one is a
little odd for me he's he's good and he
works but for some reason I kept
thinking I was listening to the sixth
doctor I don't know if it's the writing
or just sort of the way the
characterization is done or something in
the performance but he came off a bit
more flippant a bit more dismissive a
bit more cruel in his snarkiness that
seemed more Sixth Doctor ish to me than
that I'm used to seeing from Davison's
doctor I don't know if that's just me be
I don't know if anyone else and got that
vibe at all or if I just read something
weird into this performance but I I did
keep thinking like this is fifth doctor
right cuz he's and it's not like his
voice sounded like Colin Baker although
you know
as he's gotten as they've both gotten
older they kind of sounding a little bit
similar versus how they used to sound
when they first played the roles but
more in that the the tone and the
delivery reminded kept reminding me of
Colin Baker and which was weird to me
and and I'm not sure it's a bad thing
and actually especially for some of the
stuff we we find out later about what's
going on it can also probably be
explained and kind of the similar way I
talked about before I can't get too much
more into detail about that though so
I'll probably get into spoilers in a bit
if I had like a UH something that I
would actually level as a criticism on
this thing it's that it is not easy to
keep on top of the twists because the
the nature of the antimatter universe
and the bridge between them and sort of
there's a rift that the characters are
literally orbiting it it causes all
sorts of the funnel months and and
things of the characters and it means we
get a whole lot of sudden turns and
sudden revelations some of which turn
out to be real some of which there are
not to be not some of which are faked
out some of which then get reversed so
trying to keep track of who's doing what
who's aligned with whom and why becomes
difficult this is this is not one to
listen to say while doing work or to
listen to while driving like you need to
sit down and concentrate just on this
because otherwise you you're gonna like
focus on something else for like a
minute and you know just kind of kind of
listening and like properly tune back in
and go wait
now how we get here just because in
terms of the the shifting relationships
and the characters and and the
motivations it it just happens a lot it
happens frequently and oftentimes they
kind of pile on top of each other and I
don't mind being asked to engage my
brain and really follow what's going on
but this this seemed like even even
within that premise this wasn't like fun
it was like if it felt like work I don't
mind having to pay attention if it feels
rewarding this felt this spelt more like
homework and it it did take me out of it
a little bit overall though this was
this was a good a good audio and a good
piece of work I I would probably I would
rate this above master although again
that that has more to do with sort of my
own preferences and hang-ups as a Doctor
Who fan that there were very specific
things that were done in master with the
narrative that I really didn't care for
but that was still a good thing I I
liked this one a little bit better just
because even though it had some some if
heinous I like if you're if you were to
ask me which one would I rather listen
to again it would be this one so there
and there's a lot of interesting like
little tidbits and nuggets and specific
things that happen but that's all a
little bit more spoilery so I'm now
going to get into spoilers so getting
into spoilers and some of the specifics
one of the aspects I really enjoyed
about this is that it there it has
emphasis on the importance and the power
of stories because that's something that
kind of keeps coming up in terms of
omegas concern about how he is
remembered and how his story gets told
and his you know offer and sort of his
offering up different versions of things
telling a story and then telling the
doctor that's not true and but you know
when the darker kind of pushes it pushes
him on that he said well what does it
matter if it's on
I what does it matter what the lie is
and there's some some interesting back
and forth between the characters on that
topic and it's a it's a theme it's a
subject that I like in general I'm kind
of a sucker for if I'm I mean completely
honest and I also love the liked a
little bit about magic like that magic
stops working as soon as you can explain
it if you understand that it doesn't
work it only works when you can't
explain it like that's that's kind of
neat
that's a cool sentiment man it's
something that would have been
disconnect for Doctor Who because I
chose not a show with magic generally
but it's one of those things that does
get covered up as you realize that the
Omega that we're dealing with well huh
the Doctor Who we have for the first
three out of four episodes of this thing
and Omega are one and the same that he
is still that he's torn in this body
that he copied off the doctor back in
Arkham infinity so once you realize that
and then suddenly things like the talk
about magic make more sense because you
know it's it's a guy arguing with
himself and not even realizing that he's
doing it and that's sort of where things
come in and what I talked about earlier
in terms of how I'm okay with things
like the implications of the master
actually causing a genocide and wiping
out this planet by accident rather than
Omega having done it intentionally or
you know by not intentionally but making
a choice that he knew would result in
that like that's a that's a twist that I
wouldn't like if the narrative forced me
to believe it to be true but again the
sources are so questionable on pretty
much all of this and you know everyone
keeps having their brain addled and
taken over by other people and like
they're all they're all acting weird and
they're all saying strange stuff at
various points I don't have to accept
that as fact and I choose not to for the
record not just because isn't something
that
I don't think the doctor should have on
his on his back but also because I don't
like tying up the doctor into omegas
origin there's no reason to do that it
doesn't have anything it just it makes
the doctor more omniscient which is not
something I like which and I alluded to
this is why I'm really glad they never
got to to conclude the story that was
eventually supposedly gonna reveal the
doctor to have been the other the other
Gallifreyan from the beginning of time
Lord Society who helped create
everything like I I would hated that if
they'd actually got around to it because
then I've talked about this in other
videos I don't like the doctor becoming
so embroiled that he's basically the
end-all be-all of like all of time of
space I don't want that from him and and
I feel like tying him into omegas origin
story effectively it is too close to
that same thing but some of the other
things I wrote down some notes in terms
of like little moments and little things
that that I thought were we're nifty or
cool the pale X Omega before he was
called Omega gets referred to as a time
plumber and initially I'm like that's
dumb would you just stick time on the
front of something but then he actually
gets elaborated a little bit that he's
clearing out the vortex tubes all the
spare bits of time that are stuck in
there and I actually something about
that's really cool like this weird
blue-collar logistical job that has to
exist for time travel that I mean that's
like thinking that's like stopping and
thinking about a TARDIS mechanic like
that's there's just something that
really appeals to me about this you know
this high concept really advanced
society that still has these blue blue
collar jobs that are just a little bit
different because the way everything
works there I being someone who enjoys
theater and acting when I get the chance
I did like the little bits of things
like real history is less popular than
the dramatized version because it's not
as entertaining which actually makes a
lot of sense if you think about it if
you were to go back
can actually watch any of the major
historical events that get dramatized
all the time and TV films books etc they
would seem really low key and really
anticlimactic more often than not but
also the whole thing where the actors
can't be Androids because of because of
equity um and basically the actors Union
and sure hang that thing yeah they can't
be replaced with androids I love that
there's also an interesting touch it
said that the Time Lords can't visit
their own history now it said it's
forbidden which to me says it's a rule
as opposed to like they've actually put
deliberate blockades and restrictions to
keep them from doing that but that that
is something that I hadn't heard said
before and makes a lot of sense I mean
the doctor I've heard the doctor say he
can't cross his own timeline because
that's a paradox situation but like the
idea that Time Lords can't visit Time
Lords sucide neo history makes a lot of
sense because of you know a potential
domino effect of messing around because
they have the power to do that now so I
thought that was a cool detail that has
probably shown up in other material but
it's my first it's my first time he
kinda ran it so there you go the whole
um angle between the the woman whose
name is now escaping me and Omega like
the sort of weird prison romance like
you know when women become pen pals with
with criminals in prison and fall in
love with them it was it was weird and I
don't know if I bought it like I haven't
how did that even start and why why was
she in love with him I don't know that
that felt like something under explored
that felt like something that needed
more justification than it got but her
performance was fine is that this is
this was a writing issue oh and I did
find it interesting the whole idea of
other time was from the future being
desperate to preserve the doctor
hero reputation there's something quite
intriguing about that because it you'd
think that would feed the wild this
makes the doctor like the most important
thing ever but it doesn't necessarily
because it's just to the side enough
because what what they're actually
saying is the reputation of the doctor
is one of the most important things ever
which is not quite the same thing and
that's just that little sidestep from
something that I wouldn't like to make
it just different enough that I'm like
okay okay I can go with that so those
are sort of the extra little details but
conclusion is the same that you know
it's what I said before I got into
spoilers this was good I enjoyed it and
I'll probably listen to it again I have
a feeling if I'm coming back to compare
it to master again I think master is a
tighter package it's just the things
that I take issue with women in master I
have a harder time sort of getting over
than the things that bug me about Omega
so but I do think masters probably a
better written and tighter product
overall I so like Omega a little bit
better myself
so Omega from Big Finish have you heard
it what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it you
know the stuff I mentioned the patreon
already but there's also the Twitter and
you can buy t-shirts and and there's a
podcast that I'm trying to get up and
running on a regular basis again I might
have actually started doing that by the
time this airs who knows check out the
links down in the description and find
out for yourself and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]